tercera jornada de movilización masiva
de los franceses contra la polémica
reforma de pensiones una de las piedras
andulares del gobierno de Manuel marrón
como vemos una gran afluencia de
personas esta tarde es una jornada
decisiva porque está esta protesta envía
un mensaje contundente a los diputados
franceses que en este preciso momento
debate en la ley en cuestión en la
asamblea nacional con el oficialismo
desplegando todas sus fuerzas para ganar
la batalla parlamentaria volcarse a las
calles Parece ser la única opción de los
franceses algunos de ellos han
compartido con nuestro equipo las
razones por las cuales acuden a esta
protección la gente está harta y han
sido muchas cosas seguidas ha sido el
covid ha sido que los salarios siguen
bajando ahora llega la inflación la
guerra en Ucrania y por si fuera poco
que la gente no pueda dejar de trabajar
después de 40 años es que es que hay que
es que hay que tener una cara dura como
tiene nuestro actual presidente no y yo
trabajando hasta los 69 años
tengo la experiencia para decir que en
realidad es una medida injusta porque
hoy día en Francia una persona
de 55 60 años no tiene la posibilidad de
seguir trabajando hasta el momento la
manifestación transcurre de forma
pacífica pero tanto diputados opositores
como líderes sindicales alertan que el
gobierno está jugando con fuego y estas
marchas hasta el momento cívicas
pudieran de generar Y radicalizarse si
El Ejecutivo francés sigue dando la
espalda a la voluntad popular